nevada state police are still not
answering questions about a tragic
accident that happened nearly two weeks
ago but the 8 news now i-team is
uncovering new information metro police
detective justin terry was killed after
a beam collapsed on the car he was
driving the i-team's vanessa murphy
obtained new documents which may help
provide insight about what exactly
happened
yeah we're trying to put the pieces
together here about what happened and
it's a challenge since nevada state
police are not providing answers but we
now have the permits for the company
which owns the truck involved metro
police detective justin terry was
driving near the centennial bowl project
on the morning of june 10th when a
tractor-trailer hit an early warning
beam for a bridge up ahead the beam
collapsed on terry's car and he died at
the scene the 8 news now i-team learned
north las vegas-based western states
contracting is responsible for that
truck according to the nevada department
of transportation the company had
10 ndot issued permits at the time of
the accident all of them for a truck 15
feet high an ndot spokesman says the
beam is
at least 15 feet high so you can see how
it didn't make it under the permits also
specify only one piece of freight is
allowed when overweight is involved a
pilot car is required and there are also
route restrictions without additional
information though it's difficult to
determine whether rules were violated
i'm also waiting to find out if nevada
state police have determined whether
that beam was properly secured back to
you